The cancer continues to grow on my one rebating kidney. I would like to discuss taking
Ivermectin in the clinics ability to provide B with it. So Ivermectin, again, we've spoken about
this a lot in the last year as a highly overlooked and underutilized and underspoken about
use of an off label, an off label use of a drug. So Ivermectin is a drug that's anti-paracidic
drug that has been shown and there are some studies you can google them. There are some studies that
show that Ivermectin can kill cancer. So I'm all for taking Ivermectin. There really isn't any
downsides. There's really not really any, it's one of those drugs that have been used for decades and
decades with very, very little side effects. So as far as the clinic's ability to provide
you with that, we have no ability to provide you with that because the only over the clouter
Ivermectin is for horses. You could buy that at a barbed-fleet store or a flea farm store
and take that based upon your weight, but that has to be done by you and I can't oversee that.
So if you want to get the human prescribed, Ivermectin, you'll have to go to a prescribed doctor to be able
to get that.